Hello Freak bitches,
you know,
that is real.
I mean,
it's,
that's not just in this talk,
that's not talk where you zig zagged.
Um,
and you know,
Roy Roy's story is a perfect example of
that and explain who roy is.
Um,
roy is,
he's who got me started in bow hunting
and he is the toughest man I've ever
met.
I've shared more experiences with Roy
and the mountains.
He's life to finding type experiences
that,
that we've talked about.
And you know,
the,
the bond we've created together has been
over a handful of experiences,
you know,
and you,
you realize when you're out of your
comfort zone like that and when you're
both so committed to a pursuit,
those bonds form quickly,
you know?
And so we've formed a strong bond over a
handful of experiences over a couple of
years will really,
and I,
um,
you know,
we went to high school together,
we started bow hunting as I think 18,
19 years old and had hundreds of
experiences,
life changing life,
defining experiences together over the
year.
So our bond naturally was like brothers
and,
um,
you know,
he,
he was,
when everybody doubted me when I was
growing up and doubted my dream of ever
becoming anything,
he never did.
He was always,
he was always the guy that believed in
me.
Well,
this year of sheep hunting,
he was up sheep hunting where we had
sheep hunted before together and I
killed around.
And it was,
you know,
it's a tough,
difficult,
dangerous hunt.
And He,
uh,
but he's more prepared or he was more
prepared for hunt's like that than
anybody in the world.
He's done it.
He's done it as much as anyone that I
know and I've been successful.
I think he's killed,
had killed nine rams and he one misstep.
He fell and died,
um,
prime of his life,
essentially 49 years old.
Um,
just,
you know,
uh,
father,
husband,
three kids,
somebody who,
even the toughest Alaska hunters looked
up to one step gone.
And that's,
you know,
that's so,
it's not just talk,
when you say zig,
you should've zagged.
There's risk,
but that's,
I mean,
if you're going to it,
it just puts everything in perspective.
That's the allure to it because I can
speak for Roya and I,
cause I know we,
we always have known about the risk.
That was part of the draw is we wanted
to go where nobody else wanted to go or
do things that nobody else wanted to do.
That was the only thing that made us
difference.
And it goes back.
That made us different.
That's,
and it goes back to,
you know,
the level,
the playing field.
Well,
we felt like,
well,
if we would go and do the hardest hunts
and the toughest conditions,
nobody else would want to do that.
But we would,
all of a sudden we were calling the
shots,
we call the shots of the mountain calls,
the shots and all that,
that hunt the mountain.
One at Roy fell and he died.
And it's a if fell 700 feet.
Right?
Yeah.
It's uh,
you know,
that where he fell just tough,
unforgiving sheep country.
And um,
you know,
once you,
once you start going there,
you're not going to stop.
And,
um,
it's one of the most dangerous hunts
sheep.
Yeah.
It's,
uh,
you know,
on that hunt specifically,
they give a hundred tags and a lot of
times there's this one sheep killed.
It's that difficult.
And it,
and I think 40% of the people never even
go because of the weather,
because of the conditions,
because it's so hard.
So they draw the tag and don't even get
up the hill.
It wasn't that there was a case with you
when you went up there grizzly hunting,
you were supposed to go sheep hunting as
well,
right?
Yeah,
no,
it was moose hunting Moose.
We were going to do a moose sheep Combo,
but there's so much snow we couldn't
even get to sheep country.
And,
um,
that was a plan where we're going to go
sheep hunting.
And that was with Roy.
That was with Roy.
Right.
So we had,
you know,
an amazing moose hunt together and I
killed a nice big bowl.
Um,
we just had just a,
just another epic adventure,
something,
you know,
a haunt that maybe a handful of people
would want to do because we were so far
back,
you know,
miles back and had to haul a moose out
over a mountain in the snow.
Uh,
very,
very difficult.
Huh.
But the ones,
it was just,
it def,
it was perfect because it's our last
hunt together.
He died two weeks later and that hunt
and capsulated everything about us,
it was just hard.
It was miserable and it was rewarding
and,
and you know,
we achieved success were not very many
people would have and we did it together
and uh,
yeah,
I mean,
and then two weeks laters was his sheep.
Putin,
there was an iconic photo that I think
was forever going to define you from
that hunt with you,
the big cut in your face and blood
streaming down your face and you send it
to me while you were out there.
Yeah.
You were,
you're saying we have,
we haven't gotten one yet.
Yeah,
we're out here hustling.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
there's this photo of you looking
grizzled as fuck with blood coming down
your face.
Snow in the background.
Yeah.
And I'm like,
uh,
yeah,
that's,
that's Cameron Hanes.
It,
it is because enrollment,
I always would,
we would always say we can make an easy
hunt hard cause we wanted it to be hard
when you went into an area where very
few people were having success.
And even with rifles,
you're going deep,
deep until area.
It was a rifle area.
So that means you,
I bow hunter had a different size of
animal that was legal.
If you're hunting with a Ra.
So if you're hunting in this area,
it was a rifle area,
had to be a little bigger,
so I had to be 50 inches wide but had to
have four brow tine switch.
So you're,
you're,
you're making it harder.
So we were there and there in the rifle
area and we got it done.
And it was,
it was the hunt that it was a hunt that
that's what we love.
We loved hard,
we just loved the test.
I mean a moose is,
well,
how am I pounds of that thing way.
We had about 600 pounds of meat.
Just the meat,
just the meat.
I mean,
how much did the animal way?
Oh,
I dunno.
Over,
I mean 1200 pounds,
probably a thousand people.
I Dunno.
It's an enormous,
enormous animal.
Until you see one,
like in,
you're there physically next to it.
You don't realize.
No,
we,
it took us hours to break,
you know,
I killed it.
Um,
it was in the evening and,
uh,
Roy and I,
we had cameraman there,
but they ended up just,
they filmed a little bit of the,
uh,
the process of breaking it down.
Then they headed back to the spike camp
and,
uh,
Roy and I stayed there,
which we like just doing it by ourselves
back there together,
saying in just saying,
he would always say,
I don't really,
uh,
what kinds of stuff that he's saying
know country girl shake for me.
Little Luke Bryan and maybe little
little,
uh,
lady Gaga,
I think.
Oh God.
Yeah.
He,
he was,
uh,
well versed,
terrible singer,
but it was,
it's just what we did.
Right.
You know,
just part of the part of the deal.
You were happy.
Oh,
successful hunt.
It was,
you know,
God,
I'm just gonna,
I'm gonna miss those times with him
because,
uh,
it's just hard knowing that the journey
we'd been through together.
That's why it's so appreciated.
And you know who else?
I know there's another example of we
hunted this year and hunted the Brown
bear together and uh,
he,
uh,
I killed this bear.
This Sao went over and was attacking the
corpse of the bear,
but the bear died.
She didn't know what was going on.
She smelled blood,
just went crazy.
The,
these brown bear are there,
big predators.
Something goes in their head,
it's going to have an issue.
So she hurt when I shot the bore,
it made a noise.
It sorta ran towards her.
She stood up,
didn't know what was going on,
knew he had made this noise.
So she ran towards where he was.
Well as soon as she hit his path,
she smelled the blood from where my
Arrow pass through them.
So she tracked him by the blood,
just basically running,
smelling blood,
blood,
blood.
She got to him and he had died already.
She started attacking him.
This is just what they do.
These are,
you know,
these aren't crying,
hugging bear.
And uh,
so she's gone and I'm,
I'm with Roy and I'm like,
I said,
she's turning on my bear and I'm like,
get off my bear.
And I'm yelling to her.
I'm like,
you know,
and so I tell Roy,
I'm like,
I said,
we've got to get up.
shoot out there.
So he shoots boom.
And she's like,
not,
didn't even,
you know,
he didn't shoot at her.
He just was making it just a scare.
Nothing.
Not like,
Hey,
get off that bear.
And she looked up and then she likes
sauce.
All of sudden here she comes sprinting
and it was like,
what is going on?
And uh,
she's like a blood friends.
Yeah.
Just,
it was so much going on at one time and
then it got something triggered in her
head and she was just crazy.
So here she comes and I killed my bears
in a creek.
She got to the creek and Roy,
he says,
if she hasn't stopped long enough
shooter.
And I said,
yeah.
So she comes up to our side of the creek
and not have an arrow knocked and you
know,
ended up,
know what I'm going to do with an Arrow,
but it's,
I don't have,
I never packed a gun.
So I just had my bow and he had,
he had the gun,
she stands up at 20 yards away and
we're,
we're standing there and it's,
and it's a standoff.
And so we think,
well,
she stood up,
she's going to see what's going on.
Um,
there was three of us standing there and
she's going to say,
okay,
um,
dropped down and leave.
So we were like,
get outta here.
And uh,
she drops down,
beeline right towards us charging.
And so roy,
boom,
and he,
uh,
he drops her,
you know,
one shot made a good shot.
He hit like Mr. Head butt hit like right
here and it was folded her right there.
And it was,
what,
what the,
what stands out for me is that,
um,
you know,
we were,
we were never worried about our lives
were at stake.
We were never worried about any,
you know,
like maybe a typical reaction would be
like,
oh my God,
we could have died or something like
that.
I,
I was just like,
I cussed because I'm like,
I was mad she did that and required Roy
to act,
you know,
so I was just,
I cussed and he's like,
he's like,
dude,
I had to,
and uh,
so we were worried about ourselves.
We were just,
we didn't want to have to kill another
bear and we weren't nervous about the
situation.
And I'm like,
I said,
I know.
It was like,
where else am I going to have somebody
that's on that same page with me that,
that's common,
that situation and not see their life
flash before their eyes.
Just do what you have to do to,
to stop the risk.
That's never gonna happen.
I'm never going to have somebody like
that in my life again.
And I think about,
we were,
you know,
we,
we knew the risks were involved in
everything that we did and we embraced
it and we were fine with it and it,
and it didn't consume us or anything.
And that's,
that's what I'm going to miss is having
somebody,
so on my same page that I can trust like
that,
you know,
roy was the best.
You would have to have someone who's
experienced that as many times it was
roy has had where it was,
he knew exactly what he had to do that
moment.
Yeah,
he did.
And he and his people know what they
have to do.
It's,
it's executing that is what's hard,
you know,
and,
uh,
so knowing what it takes,
not panicking,
being in control and then getting the
job done with one shot,
very rare.
And he was,
so roy in those situations was as,
I don't know,
everybody,
I haven't been with everybody,
but I would say he's as good as anybody
that I know of,
you know,
and uh,
um,
that's why,
you know,
when he fell and I got the news that he
fell and died.
I mean,
I could,
I could believe it I guess,
but I was mad and I'm still mad.
Um,
and I know everything happens for a
reason and I know,
you know,
he has,
he has a lot of faith and I know,
you know,
we want to think everything's going to
be okay and we'll see each other again.
I know all that,
but it still makes me mad.
Um,
because,
you know,
we missed or we missed out on a lot of
experiences we'd still love to have.
And we talked about and we were just
like,
we had these big,
big goals and big dreams and I'm mad
that that's gone.
So
it's completely,
it's not,
it's not just understandable.
It's,
um,
it's something that very few people
could probably relate to.
The kind of intimate friendship that you
would have with someone who's
experienced those kinds of hunts.
It's been in the,
in the wilderness.
That's don,
like that Moose Hunt that you were
talking about when you guys were deep,
deep in the,
in the,
in the wilderness like that.
It's,
it's something that very few people will
ever,
very few people ever experienced that,
that kind of danger,
that kind of an intimate moment in the
wilderness.
Just that connection to the wild that
you guys had together.
Right.
And so the whole point I guess with all
that is it's people say,
well you just,
you're murderous or you want to kill
such a small part of what me and Roy
experience together.
The kills were,
I mean they were,
we achieved our goal.
That was it.
It was the journey.
It was the Brotherhood.
It was,
you know,
growing up.
And that's what,
that's what hunting is.
It's not just you're out killing,
it's,
you're experiencing
nature,
its most brutal or it's most rewarding
or the entire gamut.
And when,
when that makes you who you are.
Um,
it's powerful.
And that's,
you know,
that's what hunting was to us.